once speaker always speaker how do I
intro you properly at the I I think
that's how it works once and always
there's only been 56 of us so uh we are
here at this Arc conference I just got
here two minutes ago so I I missed your
speech you people people are still
people are still talking about them
today I mean you just got up stage two
minutes ago the word is spreading yeah
you know the thing I talked about today
is about
um it's kind of what Ronald Reagan said
I I used Reagan's phrases in here in
Thatcher think you think of 43 years ago
what the world looked like high
inflation Americans held hostage um you
had this uh evil empire trying to expand
around the world it looks a lot like
today and what Rose up what what
defeated that I mean it was a rag and
Thatcher Pope John Paul II you could
have faith you could believe in the
family you believe in individual rights
and Liberty and freedom and and and it
prospered the world to something we
haven't seen before but now people
become lazy they think this victimhood
right this negative that people is
something for nothing so I really think
what Arc is here is instilling those
values once again to a world that's
badly needed right we got an evil empire
growing we've got these cities that that
that had gotten growth but now now they
celebrate a terrorist organization Hamas
terrorist attack you've got Americans
being held hostage there You've Got High
inflation um and you're wondering are we
going to fall behind I firmly believe
it's the responsibility of every
American every person in the western
culture to bound together to our
principles and and rebuild what we know
the greatness that we can be do you see
a lot of this as just a function of the
success of the West that we just got
soft it was just going to happen to a
certain extent because of how good
things have been it's like anything else
anything in life when you go to the
third generation they don't know what
the first generation sacrificed and
fought for for the fruitfulness that
they have and they become soft and you
lose that right um it's a real challenge
which was interesting I I came a day or
two early and I went over to Oxford to
do a debate I think it's the first time
an American ever won a debate at Oxford
but but but the question was about
American
intervention the proposition was is bad
you know I started the whole debate that
I was the last one and they all went on
with different points and I just said
I've never been to Oxford I've never
watched a debate uh Madam president can
can I first know my audience how many
hear their first language is German how
many hear their first language is
Russian how many hear first language is
Japanese how many hear your first
language is English two-third of the
crowd Rose their hand in English and I
said you're welcome the bait's over
right right we've done something okay
here and the other thing when they look
at American
intervention in every single War America
has gone we've gone it for democracy for
freedom and you know when we leave we
rebuild and the only land we ask for is
just enough to bury those Americans who
gave the ultimate sacrifice for them
have we just not done a good job selling
that to to our own people to the
Americans I mean who now seemingly are
very confused about what foreign policy
should be and I wor I worry about
America when they're looking at foreign
policy and part of that is what the
Democrats have done by by bringing us
such grade of debt you know so they fear
we're Tipping Point in others um but it
looks like a lot like the 1930s I mean
think of that the actions of Putin are
very similar to Hitler I mean Hitler
served in the German Army he hated they
signed the Treaty of versailes he
created a new party ran into democracy
and again and again until he was elected
rebuilt his country by rebuilding the
military even though it went against the
Treaty of
Versailles he invaded other countries um
and he took away people's freedoms Putin
didn't serve in the syvan Army but he
served in the KGB he ran for office in a
democracy respected and served two terms
got outp put medin came back took the
power away rebuilt his military and then
he realized the military makes you
strong but dependency makes you weak use
the KGB tactics to make Europe dependent
on his natural gas but as America if we
replaced Russian natural gas for one
year do you realize we would lower CO2
emissions by 218 million tons in one
year because ours is 41% cleaner but we
got a President Who attacks our own
ability for natural gas that could
Supply our allies and even even our
adversaries it have greater control over
them and then what did he do he invaded
other countries same exact tactic and
you need a strength and then it's
interesting being here in the UK and
being from America we watched in a time
like this where you had the leaders of
Reagan and Thatcher and then fate John
Paul II the three of them together
transformed the world I mean these kids
at Oxford don't understand there were
two germanies they don't understand what
was the threat they think that they
think the world is easy right and
they're at Oxford Oxford is doing a
little better I think than most of our
colleges in the states uh let's shift
back to America for a moment because
obviously you are not speaker anymore uh
I I sense kind of like a a sense of ease
from you regarding this whole thing well
look I didn't want happen happen chat
with you last night I sense you're
you're kind of okay I have look I I give
as good as I get um I would do it all
again it if it if it meant making sure
our troops got paid as they're sitting
in the Mediterranean right now wondering
if they make their car payment or their
house payment or their family back home
I know I did the right thing America
knows I did the right thing when eight
people 4% of your conference partners
with every single Democrat for the exact
same reason for political reasons to try
to take you
out I admire the fact that I'm they
think I'm that important secondly too is
my record I have been leader for 5 years
in those two election Cycles we have
only won seats of all the Republican
entities everybody else lost and you
know who we won we were able to elect
the most women in the history of the
Republican party in Congress the most
minorities in the history of the
Republican party I'm proud of what I
left and if you look at at the state
from when I when I received our party in
Congress and where I left it it is so
much better off and we're poised to win
big races next time this is going to be
one of our best election Cycles we just
had redistricting in North Carolina I
mean to Lo to lose seats in the next
cycle will be malpractice I I left us
with 20 million more than we've ever had
give the Republicans a chance there's
always there's always a way to screw
things up but do you think the part of
the messaging problem is that it seems
to me that you were fixing things and
and this is what we talked about when
when you had me at the capital you were
fixing things on margins you were taking
a system that was kind of screwy and
figuring out ways to work with the
system where the base kind of just likes
this idea that you just come in in and
Destroy Everything whether whether it
means you're going to rebuild anything
after or not and and that that sort of
the tension it's almost like they don't
want any responsibility they just want
to go on a a podcast or something else
and said they said no but the one thing
look I grew up in a family of all
Democrats but I always been a Republican
and mainly based upon Reagan and I
talked about that in here look at I'm a
I'm a son of a firefighter a grandson of
a cattle rancher I remember Carter
putting a sweater on and telling me the
the best days is behind me but I also
remember Reagan saying no pastels fly
the bold colors and go to the shiny City
on the hill being a conservative doesn't
mean you say no being a conservative
means you govern in a conservative way
to make government better we under my
speakership we had the biggest cut in
American history the largest recision in
American history we had welfare reform I
mean we have achieved even in a short
time things that we've never been
achieved before and you only had a four-
seat majority I mean after the removal
of speaker I hope people understood how
difficult it is because we went through
those three weeks I mean it's tough to
govern but you've got Democrats in the
Senate and the presidency and then when
August came they did a study of of this
congress with the last Congress under
Nancy Pelosi where the Democrats
controlled all we passed more bills we
had more become into law even though the
Democrats were in the majority I mean
you you think parents Bill of Rights hr1
make his energy independent hr2 securing
our border you know you we've never as
Republicans have passed a border
security Bill since Ronald Reagan we've
had big majorities we just did it with
four we look at the challenges we were
facing every single challenge we were
giving Solutions and look we all know
the individual who led this Gates he's
not a conservative by any means he'll
admit it to you he he has nothing to do
about conservatism he his whole goal is
about attention it's personal with him
but unfortunately it's hurting the
entire nation yeah it's interesting
because I mentioned to you last night
the guy who to me is the most
Libertarian member of comet oh M messy
he basically was like McCarthy was giv
us the the most conservative house that
we have ever had and and that wasn't in
essence good enough for Gates and that's
got to be a strange position to be in
Gates would stop us from doing the
appropriation bills and complain I
haven't done them then we we have the
most conservative stop Gap bill that
would secure our border cut uh billions
of dollars and he wouldn't vote for it
to keep government open and say if
government isn't open it's your phone I
mean it it just goes into look we we we
have the Crazy Eight led by Gates but
the biggest problem is they worked with
every single Democrat that's a deal for
rep deal with the devil one way or
another Oh by far by far all right we've
only got like two minutes left you have
other things to do I would while you're
here um what what's next for you I mean
it sounds like uh there's some options
what do you think there's a lot of
options but look want to move to the
pre- State of
Florida I got a lot of everybody else my
companies are growing what can I do yeah
yeah you might need a little help maybe
I run the cameras yeah look I have
worked too hard to get this majority to
just walk away but the one thing I've
always learned is I never give up and
that may I don't have to have the title
of speaker I don't have to have the
title of Congressman I believe too much
in our conservative values to ever give
up on that and so I sit around and look
at what I'm going to do in the future
but it's always going to be about
working towards making America more
Prosper providing people more individual
liberties and freedoms and uh this this
country is too great to give up on well
I gotta tell you man in all the years
that I've been doing this one of the
true pleasures of my career was that day
that we spent so I don't know when I
don't know when another speaker is going
to invite me to the people's house to re
I mean it was right there when reopening
everything it was truly one of the
throws of my career so well thank you
for all your great work appreciate you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell